I'm very very pleased to welcome Jeffrey
canard tonight to our series on open
source culture exploring issues in
intellectual property technology and the
arts I've known Jeffrey since the spring
of nineteen ninety-six I just moved to
New York City from Berlin and started an
arts organization called rhizome and I
realized that I didn't know as much as I
needed to know about starting an arts
organization and that I should probably
talk to a lawyer so I was very lucky to
meet Jeffrey Jeffrey then worked with us
on a pro bono basis for several years
eventually joined the rhizome board of
directors Jeffrey is also on the board
of directors of several other arts
organizations including the College Art
Association and the freer Sackler Museum
which is part of the Smithsonian
Institution he's chairman of that board
Jeffrey is a lawyer he's a partner at
the law firm of debe boys and plimpton
his specialties are intellectual
property information technology arts
media and communications he is the
author of a few books most recently
copyright law practitioners guide and I
think partly through his involvement in
various not-for-profit arts
organizations and partly through his own
enthusiastic interest he seems to know
quite a bit about art so I'm really I'm
thrilled tonight to be having a lawyer
talking about intellectual property
issues and other issues in arts please
welcome Jeffrey canard
thank you Mark for that very gracious
introduction it is unfortunately the
case that I am a lawyer and this is one
of the few times that i'm at columbia
not recruiting at the law school so for
me it's a great pleasure to be in front
of such a distinguished gathering of
non-lawyer law students what I want to
talk about for about an hour is the
intersection of art and art making and
law and law making and ask whether those
worlds collide in an open source
contemporary art practice environment in
which we find ourselves today and I hope
that will be of interest to you I will
be here of course at the end to answer
any questions that you might have this
is not the name of the case or any case
but it does sort of summarize what some
have characterized as the sort of
antagonism or the relationship between
the artistic impulse on the one hand and
the strictures of the law on the other
and indeed I have myself sampled that
case name from this statement of
principles which i think is worth
exploring this evening I was inspired by
a joy Garnett's lecture the first in
this series some of you may have been
there for it but today I want to build
on that lecture and tease some of the
applicable legal principles out of the
situation in which she found herself and
focus on how art and the law deals with
the kinds of contemporary practices in
which she and so many other artists
today are engaged in her talk in one
very pithy sentence joy summarized much
of art-making by saying it is about the
freedom to sample and appropriate that's
part of the creative process artist as
we all know sample and appropriate from
the very rich visual culture that
surround us whether
the work of photojournalists as was the
case with joy other artists commercial
content owners record companies movie
studios writers from the public domain
from iconic images from pictures of
celebrities whether or not those images
belong in some sense to others or not
this open source kind of art making is
really an inevitable part of today's
contemporary art practice but as we
shall see it is not only contemporary
art practice but one that distinguishes
the history of art making through the
sanctuaries now in the last month a
influential court of appeals in a
digital sound sampling case said well if
you cannot pirate copyrighted work you
can't lift it and you can't sample it
you cannot take anything even some minut
portion that's less than the whole and
it's memorable words words which are now
rebounding through the sort of art
making and legal community the court
said get a license or do not sample we
do not see this view this bright line
rule as stifling creativity in any way
sampling is never accidental you are
taking another's work period now of
course the law itself and other courts
are much more nuanced in the way they
grapple with these problems but
nonetheless the fundamental issue
remains is appropriation open-source art
making in inevitable collision with the
law and the answer as we shall see or at
least it's my view is not that there is
in fact an inevitable collision but that
at least some type of art making does
occasionally get into the legal scrape
the fender bender if you will though
occasionally there are even more serious
injuries that occur let's start with a
preliminary matter courts grapple with
the complex questions of what is art and
how the law should treat art all the
time it's not really a contemporary
post-war phenomenon in the United States
courts have addressed this question of
what is art since at least the 20s in a
case involving this wonderful landmark
abstract sculpture
koozies bird in space the sculpture was
seized in 1927 by the US Customs Service
which sought to impose a tax on raw
material after all from the standpoint
of the custom service this was just a
hunk of metal customs refused to grant
rank using an exemption applicable to
original works of art they said hey this
isn't art now Brent qz filed suit to
have the work declared an original work
of art and indeed the following year in
1928 the court granted this sculpture
the official status of a work of art so
not all courts in fact are as Philistine
as my opening might have suggested now
to move into the meat of the subject
makers of art and perhaps courts or at
least lawyers who do battle may have to
distinguish between different types of
art-making practices this evening i
myself want to distinguish between what
we call illegitimate art making and
legitimate open-source practice and the
initial cut here is between let's say
what we call forgery and plagiarism on
the one hand and appropriation or
sampling on the other and then having
drawn that distinction I want to proceed
to identify differences among the
various types of appropriation and why
those differences may matter in the
applicable in the application of certain
legal principles essentially copyright
trademark and the individual right of
publicity and then finally at the end if
I have time I want to turn to some
special problems posed for publishers of
art and possible avenues for addressing
these problems now in some sense as we
know all artists are open source every
artist borrows from and stands on the
shoulders of those who have gone before
and I will turn in a few minutes to the
different kinds of borrowing practices
that we see from wrote reproduction to
variation to highly transformative
adaptations and finally to drawing in
artistic inspiration in terms of style
and idea from people who have practice
start before us but while these are all
variants on kind of legitimate artistic
art making let's first try to focus on
what is forgery and plagiarism and how
does it differ from this kind of
appropriation forgery in the law is an
intense
sive usually for financial gain by
offering an art object as representing
something other than it is while
appropriation for at least for purposes
of this lecture will call the use of a
pre-existing work the modification of
that work in some way creating a new
work albeit one that may be very very
very very very close if not identical to
the original so here we need to take a
cultural differences in the evolution of
artistic practices over time the
tradition of artistic inspiration rather
than of clear-cut cases of forgery is
perhaps most ingrained in classical
Chinese painting Southern Sun painting
inspires Ming painting and Ming painting
is the inspiration for late Ching
painting but the line is blurred indeed
a famous Chinese scholar zhengzhou
himself wrote if my poems and paintings
which are only small efforts to me
should prove to be of some aid to
forgers what is there for me to grudge
about well let me start with some images
from that Chinese tradition as Mark
mentioned I have the honor and the
privilege of being involved with the
National Museum of Asian art the freer
Sackler galleries in Washington a couple
of years ago we had an exhibition of the
works of bada shen Renick shang dynasty
master principally working in the late
17th century his favorite themes were
flowers birds fishes and his paintings
were known for a flat angular brush
stroke and the technique of layering ink
in a particularly specialized way now
three of his paintings and actually many
more were forged in 1930s by Zhang
Duncan who was one of the greatest
traditional Chinese painters of the 20th
century and a major forger of this
fellow's works his forged paintings bear
the signatures and seals of bada Shen
Ren he replicated almost every aspect of
the original but he altered some
elements and his forgery was revealed
only through a comparison of brush
strokes and his use of ink now I'm going
to run through three of these and we'll
see if any of you can tell the original
from the the forgery
hard to tell i suspect well the ones on
the left were the originals now what
makes them forgeries and what
distinguishes them from legitimate
artistic appropriation are the elements
of deception and fakery right this
strikes us is not legitimate artistic
appropriation it's simply not right but
if copyright law were applicable and it
is not these would be reproductions or
at least derivative works and as such if
badas works were not in the public
domain he or his heirs could probably
have sued Jang now let's take a look at
another example of forgeries this time
from works that may be a bit better
known to you involving one of the
greatest painters of all time a Vermeer
first let's look at a couple of
originals this is an original that's an
original but now let's look at a couple
of forgeries these were forged in the
middle of the 20th century by hans and
Meegeren a dutch artist who specialized
in foraging Vermeer he was convicted of
fraud he died a few weeks after his
trial in 45 would Vermeer's heirs have
had a right to sue for copyright
infringement again assuming
hypothetically that these works were not
in the public domain well maybe not
because Van Meegeren did not in fact
copy any actual expression of Vermeer
there was no little reproduction in toto
of any single Vermeer work and so this
raises the question of can an artist
protect his style as opposed to the
literal expression or images he creates
and we'll turn to that in a few minutes
having now talked a little bit about
forgery and plagiarism let's focus on
artistic appropriation itself which is
the meat of of the talk as joy Garnett's
experience begins to illustrate for
those of you who heard her open source
art making may run afoul of the law she
made a painting from a photo taken by a
photojournalist some couple of decades
before and received a threatening letter
from the lawyer for that photojournalist
Susan my zealous which spawned
exchange of some intensity and joy war
including a active discussion I believe
in on rhizome let's talk about the
different types of artistic
appropriation that we might be examining
today first there's artistic inspiration
that relies on themes and composition
there is then transformation of the
original essentially you take an
original work of art you transform it
there are two types of this
transformation you modify the work
itself you do something to the actual
work or you don't do anything to the
actual work but you somehow
recontextualize it and finally there's
literal copying copying without war
calling a copy one's own a classical
postmodern practice but not of course a
forgery now on this spectrum the risk of
collision between art making and the law
would seem to increase the further along
the spectrum one goes with the maximum
risks raised by literal copying why is
that I'm going to spend just a couple of
minutes on copyright law because I
suspect they're not a lot of lawyers or
law students in the room but let's just
recap for a moment the essentials of
copyright copyright gives the artist or
other copyright owner the exclusive
right to reproduce the work there can't
be any unauthorized copies or
substantially similar works the
exclusive right to adapt the work so you
can't make a photo or a film of a
sculpture you can't make a sculpture
from the photograph you can't make a
painting from a photograph gives the art
the copyright owner the exclusive right
to publicly perform the work it's
important to understand this is very
important in the museum world by the way
that the ownership of the physical copy
is not the ownership of the copyright
there's a distinction between the copy
and the copyright the owner of the copy
can do with the copy what she wishes
with it but can't do anything that
implicates the copyright owner's rights
absent permission or fair use or some
other exception in the law and finally
no one can exercise copyright / ideas as
opposed to expression there is also the
notion that copyright is a strict
liability statute innocence is no
defense good faith is really no defense
but there is a fair use provision which
we'll get to
a moment that at least four artists can
be a significant limitation on the
exclusive rights of the copyright owner
this safety valve was the subject of
some discussion by joy but before I want
to get before I get to the discussion of
fair use I want to talk a little bit
about the difference between style
versus expression which I mentioned a
moment ago because i say as i said a
copyright owner has no control over his
or her artistic style only over the
expression of that style let me
illustrate this with an example drawn
from two works of Cristo Christos
wrapping of the pond nerf was world
famous of course to news companies had
used photos and films of the wrapped
bridge taken without Christos Authority
he sued and the court found that the
artwork was in fact original expression
the idea of accentuating the pureness of
the lines of the bridge and it's lamp
post by means of cloth and ropes was an
original work eligible for protection
but Cristo then sued an advertising
agency which had disseminated photos of
a swimming pool covered in pink cloth
presumably contending that the idea of
covering water in that material was an
infringement of his well-known work in
Biscayne Bay Illustrated here the court
denied him the relief saying that the
law only protects creations of
particular individualized objects and
not a category or family of forms that
have features in common because only
because they are part of the same style
christo could not protect this idea of
his what he could protect was the
expression of the idea now let's turn
back to fair use because much of the
rest of the talk will depend on the
understanding of the nuances of fair use
and how it might come into play this is
variously the client coming to the
lawyer the lawyer going to the Copyright
Office or some other variant because in
fact no one really has any absolute
certainty as to what is fair use and
there's the rub fair use as joy
explained is a doctrine built into the
copyright law for those
you weren't at her lecture here's
another 30 second recap fair use can
permit appropriation of works for
certain purposes such as scholarship
criticism teaching or reporting there
are factors that courts take into
account and we'll talk about some of
them this evening one is the purpose and
character of the use for artists this is
one of the most important of the factors
because the key here is is the work
transformative the more transformative
the work is the more likely it is to be
a fair use and therefore fall outside
the exclusive rights of the copyright
owner and that's probably good news for
most artists working in in today's
contemporary art practice because most
of them are transforming the work that
they're taking in some fundamental way
another factor which is identified at
the bottom of the screen is the effect
of the use on the potential market for
the original the more likely that the
work is to be transformative the less
likely it is to have an adverse effect
on the market for the original and we'll
go through some examples of that today
so at least with respect to copyright
law we have some perspective on when
open source appropriation might not be
considered a fair use and therefore fall
within the exclusive rights of the
copyright owner first let's talk a
little bit about artistic inspiration
and because we there was one slide there
of legal principles and now we have to
get back at looking at art let's start
with the most famous sequence of
artistic inspiration which is based on
an action of a lost drawing by Raphael
the judgment of Paris and this was the
inspiration as we will see for painting
by Monet two paintings by Picasso and
relating this story I should say that
I'm indebted to an essay by carsten
Schubert called Rafael's shadow on
copying and creativity which appears in
deer images are copyright in culture
marcantonio Raimondi had copied Rafael's
the judgment of Paris which had been
held in very high esteem by much of Rome
he did so because he was employed by
Raphael and he copied the drawing with
the artists consent if he had not done
so that would
have been copyright infringement had
that been a cause of action back in the
16th century the Raphael is lost the
etching is the only firsthand record of
Raphael's work and I want to focus your
attention on the grouping in the lower
right hand side it appears with respect
to this grouping that Raphael himself at
least as to this aspect of the
composition had been inspired by an
arrangement on a Roman sarcophagus at
that time in the villa medic she in Rome
and I say hey this is a fair use here's
a close-up of that composition men a
turned to the raimondi print as Raphael
was considered at that time the greatest
master in painting and drawing he made
the figurative group at the periphery of
Raphael's composition the center of his
own in this very famous painting a scene
from a purportedly contemporary life in
19th century France the dizziness arab
of course the painting caused an outcry
due to its shocking subject matter for
any of you who've taken in art history
101 now is that a fair use well I'd say
so now Picasso solid as Rene in Paris in
1900 and his demoiselles d'avignon in
1907 are a direct reference to the
painting he eventually acknowledged the
relationship between the two paintings
but I'd say that they're sufficiently
different cost of being sufficiently
transformative here it's definitely a
fair use now later on in the middle of
the 20th century picasa began his
addition a series and in June 23rd 1961
he drew this scene as Miss Schubert the
author of the essay describes it a
dramatically foreshortened woman bending
forward and gathering up her chemise a
suited man with hat and walking cane
seated in profile against a tree and
mayonnaise painting is the obvious
source for this composition called
there's addition a after men a and what
do we think well it's highly
transformative right even though it's
clearly appropriation let's turn then to
from artistic inspiration the borrowing
of themes and so on to transformation
that the kind of addition that is you
take the original but you add something
to
here's some here's some images drawn
from contemporary art making the
Japanese artist mota mota is known for
taking old master paintings and painting
himself into the picture and leaving
aside the fact that the underlying works
are in the public domain it seems to me
that this form of highly artistic
transformation would seem to be fair so
some of you may recognize this painting
by Caravaggio Bacchus but certainly no
one would think that this mota mota riff
on the Caravaggio original would
displace the market for the original at
least I don't think so or let's take
Olympia and no one would think that this
again is displacing the market for the
original assuming that there were such a
market now before I move on from from
painting to sort of new media let me
talk about the special case of
photographs and indeed other new media
such as motion pictures and video
photographs were really in some sense
the first new media because paintings
and sculpture were around for hundreds
if not thousands of years and they've
posed special challenges for lawyers and
lawmakers one of the challenges of
photographs is that they capture reality
in a very obvious way and the
photographs can be made quickly easily
and cheaply and fundamentally they can
be easily reproduced and readily
appropriated now as joy herself learned
photographs are a separate species of
copyrightable work whether or not the
underlying work the work that's being
photographed the Statue of Liberty a
celebrity your best friend another
copyrighted work a Molotov bomb-thrower
is itself the subject of copyright
protection there's one significant
exception to this principle that
photographs are copyrighted well and
i'll talk about that at the at the end
now should photographs be copyrightable
good question John Ruskin wrote in the
stones of Venice in the end of the 19th
century a photograph is not a work of
art though it requires certain delicate
manipulations of paper and acid and
subtle calculations of time in order to
bring out a good result and we'll see
that as I say at the end of
the lecture echoed in a decision of a
few years ago here in New York in the
case involving the bridgeman art library
but in 1869 just a few years later the
British courts held that photographs
were indeed copyrightable and that's the
rule in the United States I've lingered
here to discuss photographs because the
next set of images involves photographs
in other new media and because it seems
that photograph autauga furs are among
the most proprietary of copyright owners
as joy found out painters really sell
them sue painters who appropriate their
paintings but photojournalist seem more
likely to sue and I've given some
thought as to why that might be the case
well it may be because that's the way
the industry is structured
photojournalist just arm or proprietary
breed and depend a lot on the sale of
their images it may be because they have
less sympathy for artists appropriators
although I don't think that's the case
but it may be because a copy of a
photograph like a copy of a movie or a
copy of a video or a video game
substitute so immediately and so
directly for the original unlike a copy
of a painting and that's what was seems
odd about joyous experience there's no
question that Joy's painting of the
photograph was in no sense really a
substitute for the original let's return
then to some some of the types of
appropriation I don't know how many of
you would recognize this image this is
taken from the work of Paul Pfeiffer who
manipulates video art and video images
to make new video works he two samples
from historic moving images whether from
sports of the world of entertainment he
uses iconic images of heroes to look at
questions of identity not a hero in this
particular example and historic events
his idea is to sort of decontextualized
moments in time and then recontextualize
them in his own artistic practice and
look at the influence of technology on
art making now does anyone recognize
this that's right but this is a work by
Paul Pfeiffer called the pure products
go crazy
to second loop of basically an
unrecognizable Tom Cruise in his
tighty-whiteys humping the sofa from
risky business now he doesn't always use
movies this image which is hard to see
is from Long Count a video triptych
based on Muhammad Ali's fights against
Sonny listing George Foreman and Joe
Frazier what he does is he removes the
key figures from the events including
the boxers and the referees leaving a
looped image of the crowd here's another
excerpt from a digital video loop called
Goethe's message to the new Negroes
number one number two and number three
for night from 2002 and again he's
appropriated perhaps significant images
without the permission of the copyright
owner although it is interesting when
you see this image on a website from
which I took it it says copyright the
artist another one the digital video
loop corner piece from 2002 features
footage of a boxer being treated in the
corner during a match it creates the
effect of as you could see infinite
spatial recession as if you're sort of
putting two mirrors across from one
another and finally live-evil another
video installation of his the artist
morphing the dancer Michael Jackson here
he splits Jackson in half and reflects
the image in the kind of war shock like
way now all of his manipulations seem at
least to me as highly transformative as
fair uses let's talk about another
artist he's been accused of
scene-stealing and worse John Ralston a
baltimore-based artist takes video
cameras into movie theaters and points
the cameras at the screen just like
pirates do and the new york times last
year wrote a story about bootleg film
and video taping noting that routes and
himself makes art that tackles the
practice of bootlegging he takes the
digital video that he's shot he put
converts it to MPEG he burns the movie
onto a DVD and this is a kind of format
conversion it's a transformation is it
not or is it really bad bad bad now in
an interview routes and himself said I
guess it's theft and others may agree
with him for example
one writer Jerome du Bois says let's be
clear mr. Watson illegally snagged a
copy of a complex artwork which costs
blood sweat tears time and money none
his then sat on his ass in front of his
technology and cut apart a piece of work
he couldn't conceive a thousandth of on
his best day now this is a an excerpt
from commercial break stills from route
sins cremaster which is the edited for
television version of matthew barney
film cremaster for now it may be that
because routes and is appropriating the
work of some other iconic artists who is
quite quite popular and well known that
this has aroused the ire of others in
the artistic community now what is in
fact the difference between bootlegging
and what this artist does does it in
fact make a difference because he
exhibits the works in galleries and then
he doesn't sell his bootlegs on the
cheap in substitution for the original
is this a kind of recontextualization
the space in which the art itself
experiences that somehow fundamentally
alter the work and we'll talk about that
a little later when we focus on Douglas
Gordon the issue is not resolved what is
resolved though is that his art making
practice is illegal because it is a
felony in New York California and
elsewhere to go into a movie theater
with a video camera and it's soon if
Congress has its way it will be a
federal law violation well it will be a
felony under the artists right and theft
protection act which Congress is on the
cusp of enactment now he doesn't always
go into movie theaters and shoot the
entire movie on a video camera here
instills from his Carrie Porky's
originality neatness and hygiene he has
manipulated images from to shower scenes
from to movies so there is in fact a
recontextualization and transformation
of the work not unlike Pfeiffer as we'll
see in a moment Christian markley I what
about another kind of appropriation
which involves media conversion that is
to say in this either from a painting to
a sculpture or from the photo to a
painting as joy Gannett did or in the
case that I'm about to show you from a
print to a painting this is not really
wrote or slavish copying but is infusing
the original with the artistic
sensibility and the style of the
appropriator here is a print from one of
here oh she goes 100 famous views of Edo
called the plum garden at comido and
here is a remarkably similar painting by
Van Gogh he painted his Japanese IV in
1887 and this is indisputably a copy
although with some indeed quite a large
number of original elements not to
mention stylistic differences but then
go like many other master painters was a
famous copy SD copied Rembrandt delicado
Mia and he gave no thought to copying
the hit or sheegay aside from the fact
that it was in the public domain now
with van Gogh's copying the copyright
infringement today again in my view
given the transformative nature of this
painting this ought to be regarded as
legitimate artistic practice and within
the bounds of fair use now another kind
of appropriation is appropriation by
incorporation taking the entirety of the
work and putting it in a different
context as Mark mentioned in his
introduction of joy garnett artists have
been making collages for a very long
time Picasso Braque and gree put found
objects into their collages and no owner
of the newspaper or the placard or
billboard ever sued any of them at least
so far as we know I mean also i should
note going back to one of our sort of
elemental copyright principles it's in
fact not a violation of copyright law to
take an actual object a newspaper
clipping for example or a sketch of an
artist and put it into another work what
is potentially a copyright violation is
when that is read the second work is
reproduced either in a in a catalog or a
prince or filmed because then you're
making a copy of the artwork that's
incorporated here's an example take it
from a real live case there was an
artist lebbeus woods who created a
pencil drawing entitled neo mechanical
tower upper chamber depicting a high
ceiling chamber to chair mounted into a
wall and a sphere suspended by a metal
frame it was published within a
copyright
halation of his drawings in 1992 and for
extra credit does anyone recognize this
that's right so in 1995 universal city
studios released the movie 12 monkeys
ten points to columbia over here in the
left hand side of the room and in this
opening scene and in subsequent scenes
they use this clear derivation of woods
is drawing so what happened well the
court rejected the argument that this
was a de minimis fair use and found in
favor of the artist similarly with
respect to this quilt by the artist
faith ringgold HBO and b ET aired a
television program which had in the
background this quilt used in whole or
part for about 26 seconds ringgold owns
the right the high museum owns the
original ringgold brought suit and guess
what she won the court concluded that
the instances in which the poster were
visible were not trivial or de minimis
the court rejected her the argument that
there were no protectable aspects of
this highly distinctive artwork that it
were discernible the defendants had said
well son all that you really can see on
the screen is some vague stylized
painting that includes black people and
the court responded that is about like
saying that a videotape of the Mona Lisa
shows only a painting of a woman with a
wry smile now query whether the case
would have come out differently if it
hadn't been through HBO and B et but if
it had been an artist a painter who had
made a transformative painting of of
this image Rauschenberg unlike Brock
gray and Picasso has been sued for the
practice of incorporating objects into
his artwork in 1976 of photographer
Morton Beebe discovered that his photo
named the diver had been incorporated
into a Rosenberg print not this one
Beebe was upset because Rauschenberg was
a proponent of artists rights he sued
rauschenberg for ten thousand dollars in
profits the matter settled with the
photographer accepting $3,000 a copy of
the print + a commitment that if the
print were ever exhibited he'd get
proper credit now
rauschenberg use in my view what's
clearly transformative but because he'd
use the entirety of the work of a living
commercial artist he did in fact have
some litigation exposure now any of the
people in this room actual practicing
artists 12 so not not a big group but
lest you think that you're you could be
immune from suit just because you may
not have the fame yet of Rauschenberg
let me remind you of a case that was
brought right here in New York involving
a student who had her work a collage
displayed at the Whitney Museum she
didn't corporated 8 images that were
copies of photographs from living with
the enemy a book of photographs
documenting domestic violence against
women the photographer was a prominent
photo journalist named Donna farhat oh
the collage was shown at the Whitney in
a show the subject of rape where it was
labeled an original work of art and the
catalogue of the show the artist was
sued the defendant argued that her use
was fair and the case was never brought
to adjudication to judgment because the
court urged at the party settled and in
this case the photojournalist ended up
dropping the suit more or less what had
happened in some way shape or form with
with joy Garnett went sir push comes to
shove the the plaintiffs decided not to
go forward another case involving
incorporation and modification of a
photo arises out of a suit brought by
Thomas Hepler who's a well-known German
photography he sued Barbara Kruger and
artists who's an artist and galleries
and museums for copyright infringement
she'd created a work by cropping
enlarging the photographic image and
then silk-screening it in superimposing
these three red blocks which say it's a
small world but not if you have to clean
it the work was displayed prints were
sold and the work was used in
advertising Krueger was found to have
infringed hepers work classic form of
appropriation she used the work she
modified it and clearly what was in the
courts mind here was that there was an
obvious and widespread commercial
exploitation of hepers photographs now
it's turn again to everybody who's
working today appropriation by
incorporation assemblage of sampled or
mixed clips into a montage is among the
principal modes of the open-source
contemporary artist I'm going to show
you a few clips from christian marclay
video quartet 2002 he's focused his
artistic intentions on rhe
transformations of sound vision music
and performance and this work is
propelled by the relationship between
sounds and images what we hear and what
we see it's a 13-minute musical
composition 600 separate film clips for
simultaneous channels projected onto a
40-foot long screen this was
commissioned by SF MoMA and the Museum
of Modern Art and Luxembourg it
represents a very important step in new
media art because in the way in which
this work was created which I won't go
into today but what Mark Lee does say
about the work is it's all about
manipulating fragments creating a new
narrative really the subject of this of
this talk you could use the database of
clips he constructed whole scenes by
stringing the clips together and it was
a very challenging task it's undoubtedly
a highly transformative work he
juxtaposes images at the same time he
combines images with sound and he
combines the bits and pieces over time
that is to say the length of the film to
form a narrative if you watch this
you'll see and hear that includes Jimi
Hendrix on guitar and Ella Fitzgerald
felonious monk Maria Callas Elvis and
not with the Sex Pistols and many many
more since the late 70s marclay has
engaged in auditory sampling essentially
sound collages this is from a another
video work which I'll talk about in a
moment historically he's used skipping
records loops from records he's broken
records up and reformed the fragments to
create new records which he's then
played and multiple turntables all
highly transformative work really a
massive recontextualization of the
original and I would argue that sort of
appropriation is very very very unlikely
ever to subject him to an action
for copyright infringement but is the
laws collective response as we heard
from at the very beginning of this talk
get a license well I think not because
getting a license for someone like Mark
Lee would be a highly complex very
daunting undertaking which in point of
fact probably would pose an
insurmountable obstacle to this work
being created and that would be true I
think for a lot of new media artists
this image is from a work of his called
telephones it's an earlier work from
1995 it's seven minutes long uses an
archive of film clips from Hollywood
films and the theme here is the
relationship of people to the telephone
and the emotions they convey Oh over the
telephone the clips themselves are on
the order of five seconds highly
transformative fair use now let's turn
to appropriation by kind of wrote
copying this is a an image for 20 from
24 hours psycho by Douglas Gordon the
well-known Scottish artist created in
1993 it is in fact the famous 1960
Hitchcock masterpiece psycho prolonged
elongated to a full 24 hours that was
shown at the hirshhorn earlier this year
does the slowing down of this work in
fact transform it it's really a
transformation of the earth the
experience of the work to be sure it was
different from the original and that
there was no audio track now the law may
in fact recognize that there are
differences in the artwork itself based
on the perspective and the perception of
the viewers how they experience the work
and of course in terms of the effect on
the market for the work no one who wants
to rent psycho this weekend for a
Hollywood Halloween night viewing is in
fact instead going to trot down to the
local museum and sit through 24 hours of
this movie to watch the shower scene but
psycho by the way does seem to inspire
like Barbie who will get to it a bit
appropriation over and over Paul
Pfeiffer created work called self
portrait is fountain he takes the famous
shower scene he reproduces it in its in
a whole bathroom with
I l's plastic curtain running shower no
body no blood but he says everything is
this fight for talking everything is
exactly what is in the film scene minus
the body or blood but of course it is
not exact it is highly transformative
it's creating a three-dimensional
installation from a two-dimensional
image and obviously that's the kind of
transformation that the law should
sanction not condemn it's another
wonderful image from psycho now there is
this kind of wrote copying if you will
with some transformative elements even
in painting to painting this is a
painting by Mike bit low who makes full
size faithful copies of paintings by
leisure Suzanne matey's Pollock
liechtenstein Picasso he attaches
signatures and renames in this case not
leisure now to turn to a another thread
of this discussion dushawn this image
allows me to linger for yet another
moment on what sort of work is actually
protected against appropriation we saw
earlier that the brook uzi was declared
to be a work of art and would qualify
for copyright protection copyright
requires originality but one question is
how original does the work have to be
united states the test of originality
isn't minimal now are the dushawn
ready-mades sufficiently original to be
protected here we see his famous or
infamous fountain does removing an
object from its context and calling it
art without more satisfy the
requirements of a risk artistic
expression sucks that this is an
original work of art and therefore
Duchamp if he had been so inclined could
have prevented others from making copies
of it by doing the same thing themselves
unclear what is clear is that Mike bid
Loeb inspired by the Dashon made this
work which is five thousand drawings /
made over a period of five years on the
theme of desean's urinal and I would
again argue that this is highly
transformative now let's talk about
something that is really wrote copying
the quintessential postmodern
appropriator in some sense then is
sherrie levine who copied and did
frankly not much more than copy an
original photograph some of you may be
familiar with this work although what
this work actually is is probably
unclear to you because in 1936 Walker
Evans photographed the burrows a family
of sharecroppers in depression-era
Alabama in 1979 sherrie levine
rephotographed Walker Evans photographs
from the exhibition catalog first and
last is this it or not well in fact this
is an image by the artist michael mann
der Burgh who created a website after
sherrie levine and taking appropriation
to the logical next step of course there
is now a website after michael mann der
Burgh let's talk about the special case
of parody it's a special type of
appropriation and it's classically
considered to be a fair use what is a
pro what is a parody it is an
appropriation that at least the Supreme
Court has said needs to appropriate the
work in order to lampoon or criticize it
the parody does not work unless the work
itself is taken and the Supreme Court
and sort of a bit of a literary leap try
to distinguish satire from parody satire
it said is using a work to make fun of
something else and satire is not as
privileged as parody let's take this
famous at least to those of us
practicing in the area and somewhat
humorous example to illustrate what we
mean by parody once again it is a
photographer who is suing here the
plaintiff is Andy Lee bovitz she sued
claiming that her famous photo of Demi
Moore on the left was infringed by
superimposing the head of the actor
leslie nielsen on moore's body the
purpose of the work on the right was to
advertise the movie Naked Gun other 10
points for Columbia but leave of its
lost because the use was adjudged to be
a parody a fair use and of course that
would be a parody and Leonardo probably
wouldn't have had much of a claim and
that and then we have this by botero I
don't really want to focus on moral
rights because I don't have the time to
do it but perhaps the Leonardo might
have
had a claim against dushawn and boot
arrow for despoiling dishonouring his
famous work it's a whole other category
of legal doctrine that we don't have
time to get into now when we talk about
fair use we can't ignore the famous case
decided some years back here in New York
involving fair use and an asserted
parity which involved in media
transformation and the artist Jeff Koons
who lost the case there was a
photographer again named art Rogers who
took this photo of eight German Shepherd
puppies which he licensed for use on
note and postcards included a copyright
notice on the back of the cards see her
Jeff Koons who is known for his
appropriation took the back of the
postcard removed the copyright notice
and sent it to fabricators for
reproduction in three-dimensional
statute telling them to copy it
literally although obviously he added
color and he put spots on the noses of
the dogs and he added some flowers and
the hair of the people but this is
clearly a highly transformative work you
go from the photo to a sculpture Rogers
sued Coons and the gallery for 375,000
for infringement and 2.5 million in
punitive damages Koons argued for fair
use he provided expert testimony that
the photo and the sculpture were
extremely different well duh of course
the lower court held for Rogers the
plaintiff the sculpture was an
infringing derivative work and he held
that Koons must deliver the artist proof
to Rogers on appeal Koons like any good
artist question how judges who have no
training in art this is not a winning
argument by the way when you go before
that court can apply legal concept to an
area they do not fully understand he
argued that the legal process itself had
a chilling effect on creativity the
court acknowledged that he'd engaged in
the practice of quote appropriation but
rejected his defense of fair use they
said it was not a parody because it did
not comment on the directly on the photo
not sure about that but it's clear to me
that the court was influenced by what
they regarded as two factors one Kunz
they thought acted in bad faith by
ripping off the copyright notice and
sending the postcard to to his
fabricators and second that there really
was a sort of a fundamental income
disparity going on here that Rogers had
been made two hundred dollars for taking
the photo and that Koons was selling
each of the quote original sculptures
for for several hundred thousand dollars
Kunz then was plain unlucky he
subsequently lost to other similar
copyright case there is some question
though whether this case is still good
law in light of the Supreme Court
decision subsequently on parody that I
mentioned now not all appropriation
artists are is unfortunate is Koons i
said i would talk a little bit about
barbie this one yeah so the Second
Circuit held that he did not engage in a
fair use and he was liable for copyright
infringement yeah so he had to pay out
and as he as I said in two other cases
he also lost I mean sort of unlucky and
his art making practice it I guess what
happens if you become you know kind of
rich and famous although as well see at
the end if you're because if you at
least become famous and well-known that
helps you in other context when we talk
about the right of publicity zor it's a
anomalous in that regard I promised you
that I would talk a little bit about
Barbie who's perhaps our most famous
cultural icon in a Mattel seems to lose
every single case in which it sue
someone for appropriation either in a
case that I'm now about to describe or
at a case involving music that makes fun
of Barbie Thomas for sites art guitars
will show it in a moment in his suit
series food chain Barbie comments on
Barbie here is barbie and the some
parodies of Barbie depicted nude in some
vintage appliances I don't know how many
of you have seen this to this so this is
an original that of course is an
original and that is a parody
the Ninth Circuit held that fourth sites
use of the Barbie image was a fair use
under copyright law because it was a
parody and furthermore that they could
use the work that he could use the word
barbie and the title of the works and
that the classic Barbie trade dressed
the kind of look and feel of how Barbie
looks could also be appropriated by by
the artist there was no showing that
Forsythe was undercutting the market for
Barbie dolls well again obvious right no
one is going to go and buy this for
their child instead of the RB original
the court in fact was so upset with what
it thought was mattel's unreasonable
position in trying to squelch artists
fair use of Barbie that it earlier this
year awarded substantial attorneys fees
to Forsythe over 1 million dollars I
don't want to spend a lot of time on the
next image except to say that sometimes
in a copyright can be used in ways that
are politically significant and some
might say appropriate or nefarious
depending on where you stand in
particular copyright played an important
role in one of the significant battles
of the culture wars involving the NEA
and federal funding for the Arts back in
the 90s those of you who are students
may not remember all of that but in an
event Congress had passed a law
restricting the type of projects that
the NEA could fund there is a very
well-known artist named David why not oh
it's who in 1990 I had a show at
Illinois State University called tongues
of flame with a catalogue essays and
interviews he made a lot of work and
this work was deemed offensive by the
Reverend Donald wildmen who may be known
to you as the head of the American
Family Association he created a brochure
that was essentially anti any a funding
and saying look at look at the dreck
that your tax dollars are funding you
can't really see this it's a large work
but there are sort of sexually explicit
images on the lower right-hand side
upper right-hand side and then there's
also this image on the right from
another work that particularly offended
wildmen because it shows Christ as a
drug addict with a hypodermic needle in
his arm so why Nara whatz was very upset
by what he regarded as the misuse of his
work of art and he sued wildmen on a
whole series of claims including
copyright defamation a violation of the
New York artist off artists Rights Act
and basically he lost on the copyright
claim he won a one dollar for a
violation of his moral rights and the
reason why he lost is because the court
said look only a very little bit of this
work was taken it was for a highly
political critical purpose and so this
kind of appropriation for really
criticism and commentary odd for a
larger political discourse was held to
be a fair use I want to turn out very
quickly to two other legal doctrines
that are implicated in appropriation one
is trademark and the other is the right
of publicity the greatest or at least
among the best-known appropriation
artists of the twentieth century of
course was Andy Warhol he's gimmick jizz
of Jackie Marilyn and of course famously
brillo boxes and campbell soup cans
trademark in a nut shell protects
goodwill in symbols identifying goods
and services virtually anything can be a
trademark protection comes from use
trademark is a source identifier where
does the product come from this can
comes from coca-cola or this bottle
comes from pepsi cola the key to
trademark law is that it is to prove it
is designed to prevent consumer
confusion so a use of a famous trademark
might in fact be permitted if there's no
actual or likely confusion in connection
with a purchasing decision or there's no
intent to confuse collapsing this strand
of trademark law for for these purposes
but in general parody or other artistic
comment is permitted there's a First
Amendment right to comment on trademark
product and appropriation of the mark
may be permissible if no consumer
confusion this is relevant to those of
you who saw Joy's talk because in the
image of the Molotov bomb thrower there
is a
bottle of pepsi and there was a lot of
chitchat on the website that in fact
she'd been threatened not by the art of
the the photojournalist but threatened
by Pepsi itself that wasn't true and in
fact it seems to me quite clear that
Pepsi would not have had much of a legal
leg to stand on but let's consider this
image for this image obviously iconic
images Warhol did not seek permission
from Campbell's Soup the company
purportedly was amused by his usage and
presumably did not want to interfere
with the artists freedom of expression
so he retained the copyright in the
image now after his death the warhol
foundation began in Turin ting license
arrangements with various manufacturers
to use his images on their products now
at that time at the time that there was
a commercial use being made of these
images the foundation in Campbell's
entered into a licensing arrangement
both parties control the copyrighted
images and neither can make licensing
arrangements without the other so the
irony of course here is that today
artists cannot appropriate these Warhol
images of famous soup cans unlike
Warhol's own artistic practice unless
they do so as a kind of fair use now as
I said several times earlier artists
today often appropriate iconic images of
real live people Warhol himself was sued
in 1996 for copyright infringement by
the life photographer of the photo of
Jackie that he used here it was not so
but sued by Jackie's estate and in
general Warhol I think it's fair to say
never got permission from the people
whose images he used now after the fact
the Warhol Foundation sought to
commercialize these images and then it
did obtain permission from the
photographer's this brings us to another
area then where the open source artist
who uses cultural icons can collide with
a different set of rights arising out of
the so-called right of publicity we've
seen this kind of use of cultural icons
in the work of Pfeiffer and Mark Lee so
far and Warhol's use is obviously
well-known again law in a nutshell right
of publicity contemplates the
notion that celebrities have a right in
their personhood they have a right to
commercial exploitation of their
likeness or their name or their voice
this is a state law right unlike
copyright and Trademark which are
essentially federal although there can
be some trademark rights at the state
level publicity rights generally do not
endure indefinitely beyond death here in
New York they expire with the death of
the celebrity and there's a sort of
fundamental tension between the First
Amendment right of the artist to use
these images and the right of publicity
and we'll see a couple of cases that
have tried to harmonize the First
Amendment with the right of publicity
and this this is one case very famous
case where dustins hoffman sued los
angeles magazine and its publisher for a
violation of his right of publicity
under california law the magazine had
run a story using computer altered
stills from famous movies to make it
seem that the actors most of whom were
long deceased were wearing the newest
spring fashions I don't have to ask you
what movie this is because it says right
there this image on the right shows
Hoffman in evening dress and high heels
and in the computer alters still his
body was replaced digitally as an artist
might do today in this case it was a los
angeles magazine without of a male model
wearing items of current designer
fashion hoffman had not given his
permission the trial court found that
Hoffman's right of publicity had been
violated and awarded him substantial
damages about three million dollars that
was overturned though by the Court of
Appeals which held that the models were
deceased generally and the language made
it clear that the body really wasn't
that apartment but was of a digital
manipulation so in this case the First
Amendment one now here's an artist you
know who those of you are at Columbia
may not be intimately familiar with it's
a artist Rick Rush who paints famous
sports figures in historic sporting
events this is entitled the Masters of
Augusta commemorating Tiger Woods
historic 1997 victory of the Masters
Tournament Tiger Woods didn't give his
permission to make this image Sudan
trademark false endorsement and right of
publicity ground the district court the
lower court found
that this was artistic expression
seeking to express a message and the
First Amendment protected it last year I
think it was the Sixth Circuit affirmed
this decision and said that woods right
of publicity were not violated because
this work is highly transformative and
has substantial informational and
creative content here rush has added a
creative component of his own to woods
identity and permitting woods right of
publicity to trump russia's right a
freedom of expression what extinguishes
right to profit from the creative
enterprise and we conclude that
society's rights outweigh would a tiger
woods personal right so that's really a
very good decision for all sorts of
appropriation artists but then we have
this decision and there's a decision I'm
about to describe involving these images
the California Supreme Court held in a
case brought by the owner of rights to
the three stooges that an artist who
basically made images that look like
this I don't actually have the three
stooges image for perhaps reason that
will become obvious that this artist was
not protected by the First Amendment
because in this case they said that the
work was not sufficiently transformative
it basically was work that tried to
reflect the actual likeness of the
celebrity but was not did not have some
sort of artistic inspiration independent
of that likeness kind of a dangerous
test if you ask me they said there was
no significant transformative or
creative contribution it was quote
conventional and people were buying the
work because it showed the Three Stooges
not because it was a work by in this
case the artist Gary cetera who is
probably unknown to to most of us so the
the teaching of this case maybe if
you're famous or the work is highly
transformative you've got a First
Amendment right but if you're less
famous or your work is closer to the
likeness you don't and indeed the judges
went on to say talking about Warhol even
though he wasn't really directly
involved in the case well of course Andy
Warhol conveys a message that beyond
goes beyond the mere commercial
exploitation of celebrity images and
it's a form of ironic social comment
on the dehumanization of celebrity
itself it's a wonderful kind of art
historical comment by the justices of
the California Supreme Court but it
advantages Warhol over for mr. SATA room
so is it fair that Warhol is protected
because he's better known because he's
arguably more talented because the work
is more transformative is that really
fair and won't this in some measure come
down to courts imposing their own
artistic judgments on their preferences
for particular types or styles of work
without really valuing the appropriation
artists contribution to larger artistic
and social discourse and now just to
wrap up I want to spend a couple of
minutes on another class of repurposing
of art which is very much on my mind in
my capacity as counsel for the college
art association this is art publishing
particularly in a critical context
whether in online journals or in
hardcopy journals or hard copy journals
that eventually find their way to
electronic media usually when you're
public when you're a publisher you ask
that the contributor clears the rights
in the artwork or photograph that
accompanies the the article this can be
problematic for for the contributor
because sometimes it's difficult to
clear the rights but and more often than
not the author is required to indemnify
the publisher if the rights and
photographs and artworks that accompany
the article are not cleared and most SAS
scholars contributors to journals really
don't have much of the wherewithal to in
fact make their indemnity worth the
paper that it's printed on if the rights
aren't cleared then the publisher and
author can be sued for copyright
infringement unless there is some sort
of argument of fair use now here I want
to talk a little bit about the case of
the bridgeman art library had promised
that earlier there is a case that stands
for the proposition that the photographs
of two-dimensional works in the public
domain are not themselves copyrightable
so remember what I said earlier that
most photographs are copyright of all
well there is a case that says that if
only technical skill is involved in the
making of the photograph then there is
not enough
sort of creativity or artistic
expression to protect the photograph and
so the court says in a case which holds
that you can't get protection for slides
that are absolute faithful reproductions
of a public domain work where the court
says transparencies here these were
slides stand in the same relation to the
original works of art as a photocopy
stands to a page of typescript a doodle
or a Michelangelo drawing well maybe
that means that Cherie Levine's work is
not independently copyrightable because
she was in fact trying to make a slavish
reproduction of some underlying work
leaving aside that that work was
probably not in the public domain the
Walker Evans work so that's a perhaps a
troubling decision for some kinds of
artists who may be using technical skill
mere technical skill as opposed to
artistic expression but it's a great
decision for art publishers and SAS and
others who want to use photographs of
works that are in the public domain a
photograph taken by somebody of the
Sistine Chapel or the Mona Lisa let's
talk a little bit then about through a
fair use and how that operates if you're
a publisher it may be the case that
publishers are unwilling to rely on fair
use due to its uncertainty fair use is
not certain in its application as I hope
you will have gleaned from the last hour
because it depends on how courts way
these factors and publishers may want
some higher degree of certainty which is
really impossible in the world of
copyright so they rely on fair use and
risk getting sued or they ask permission
and get turned down or what we find is
the potential of authorial
self-censorship basically authors
increasingly may only be using images
that can be cleared or that are in the
public domain government commissioned
images which means that the world of
images that can be used to tell our
collective story that are still in
copyright may not be used and that of
course is a troubling development for
for scholars as well as for publishers
this does highlight the importance
though of the creative commons and other
initiatives to put try to put more work
in
to the public domain or make the work
freely licensed but that's still a
fairly nascent though very important
undertaking but it also underscores the
importance of the whole get a licence
view of the world because if you always
have to get a license and you can't find
the artist or the photographer who's
made the work that's being used in an
art journal you basically have to decide
to risk a fair use call or not publish
this is particularly the case with
respect to electronic publishing
publisher is today either are beginning
born native electronic publications or
are taking hardcopy publications and
putting them onto websites or making
them available through electronic
databases and increasingly it's getting
harder and harder to get permission from
third parties who own underlying images
photographs or works of contemporary art
because they are concerned that the
works will appear on the Internet well
as this presentation is made clear it is
very easy to take a work that appears on
the internet and put it into your
PowerPoint presentation and that's for a
legitimate fair use right but you could
imagine much more nefarious uses of some
of the images that I've shown you today
so third parties may be prohibiting
electronic dissemination which is hard
going if you're a publisher who then
wants to put your work on some
electronic database or distribute it
somehow through cd-rom they may be the
rights holders may be insisting that the
electronic rights can only be available
for a limited time so we'll give you a
license for two years what happens at
the end of the two years have to go back
and get a license for all of the images
that are in your publication I don't
think so or they may be charging higher
licensing fees for electronic
distribution one thing if you're a very
wealthy publisher but if you're a
scholarly publisher you're an academic
publisher the licensing fees may in fact
make it prohibitive to publish works
that are still still in copyright so
there are no obvious solutions here
maybe image rights owners will feel
their concerns mitigated somehow through
the use of digital rights management
technologies watermarking
ription about their problems with that
too because it may interfere with fair
use ability to use an image that is
protected by digital rights management
for a perfectly legitimate purpose
another possibility is that publishers
might be more assertive in determining
when they have a fair use right to use
the images and they may actually start
indicating in publications when they are
invoking the fair use doctrine right now
you look at a publication it never says
authorized under the fair use doctrine
but maybe publishers should start doing
something like that or this work is in
the public domain and therefore we have
every right to use it essentially
bringing to the the forefront this
notion of fair use public domain and the
ability to use images that are not
within the exclusive rights of the
copyright owners and that's a solution
that I'm working on today with with a
number of art publishers so I think what
we've learned or at least I've learned
is that an open-source art making
culture can in fact pose challenges to
the law there's in fact quite a lot of
rhetoric in law journals among on the
websites list serves about appropriation
leading to the demise of copyright for
example I think frankly that that's
overstated that the worlds of the law
and the worlds of art making can coexist
and they need not be in inevitable
collision I mean sure there will be
problems that arise from time to time
but I think the vast majority of artists
who are engaged in legitimate art making
enterprises through appropriation will
be let alone and with those somewhat
reassuring words i will stop talking
thank
I guess so now I yeah open I have self
up to questions if any or if you're all
stupefied we can all go and have dinner
yes and could you speak loudly
yes and I think I tried to the question
is if you know if the museum owns the
piece do it does the museum control the
copyright rights and in it and I don't
actually happen to know in that case but
since Ringgold brought suit I would have
said that ring ring gold was the
copyright owner it would be highly
unusual that the museum would have had
the exclusive rights in the copyright or
would have actually been assigned the
copyright which is the condition
predicate to bringing suit so I think in
almost every case you'd have to go ask
the artist or a collective licensing
Society for the artists like vaga or a
RS and so I think what happened in this
case was the producers of the television
program thought it was a quote de
minimis use in the backdrop could only
see for a you know a few seconds 26
seconds never really saw the entirety of
the quilt was a little vague a little
indistinct and so I'm sure the producers
didn't think to ask or if they did they
thought they didn't need to ask since I
also represent a major commercial
copyright owner shall we say I know it
is now standard practice particularly
among the major motion picture studios
that that sort of thing doesn't happen
again now everything is cleared or
virtually everything is cleared and it's
highly unlikely that that sort of case
would be brought today there are many
other cases though that are of great and
equal interest some of you may know that
my firm was involved in defending Sony
Pictures in a case involving the first
spider-man movie the owner of the
buildings on which to billboards in
Times Square was fixed sued sony
pictures because there is a scene in the
first spider-man movie where the Green
Goblin and spider-man are fighting at
the world unity festival over a
fictitious highly digitalized image of
Times Square the building owner brought
suit not for copyrighted
for trademark infringement and and lost
we argue there was a First Amendment
right to make a movie we said you know
guess what judges a the whole movie is
fictional you know there is no real
spider-man and therefore no one should
no one should really think that this was
an actual representation of the real
Times Square that plays into what I my
prior response by saying that in general
there is very sophisticated rights
clearance going on now for most major
motion picture studios and television
producers and so I think the ringgold
case is not a case that's likely to be
brought again yes
that's a very good question the question
is why would happy birthday in the movie
the corporation and not be a
transformative use well it would be an
it would be transformative in the sense
of recontextualization except that songs
are always being recontextualized and a
song doesn't basically exist outside of
some context I mean existed to get some
sheet music but it either exists in the
sound recording or it's being sung in a
public place or in a shower and so the
rights that the copyright owner has as I
said our to authorize the public
performance of the song the courts have
held and the law provides that the
reproduction of a song in an
audio-visual work where the audiovisual
work is shown in a public place is the
public performance of the song and
that's within the exclusive rights of
the copyright owner but making movies
such as that is in fact a very complex
undertaking with an enormous amount of
Rights clearance another matter in which
I was involved in was arises out of a
documentary some of you may have heard
of called outfoxed this is a movie by a
liberal shall we say documentary
producer about Fox News and it takes
many many many dozens and dozens and
dozens of clips of fox news programs and
sort of combines them into what is a
really very interesting documentary
about fox news programs no permission
was sought because none would have been
given and the producer was represented
very able ii by larry lessig and
stanford law school clinic and i think
they concluded that those uses which
were samples short samples in some cases
but in some cases went on for several
minutes were legitimate fair uses and i
think that's a very important precedent
for all of us as well because this was a
case that was in the spotlight everyone
understood what was going on here was
clear taking sampling of highly public
works to make a new transformative
recontextualize work oh it's actually
not unlike the
christian marclay video quartet and it
stands for the proposition that that
kind of activity i think is a legitimate
fair use but no because it was used for
criticism scholarship because you
weren't taking very much of the work
some some clips were a second or so long
and obviously there was no undercutting
of the market for the original indeed
very few people I suspect watching
outfoxed would have regarded that as an
adequate substitute for Bill O'Reilly
anyway it's a good question what do I
think about the right of publicity and
how it plays out with respect to Andy
Warhol on the one hand and Gary sattar
up on the other and I simply raise the
issue to focus you on the fact that
courts are making artistic judgments all
the time and maybe making judgments with
respect to the quality of the artists
the fame of the artist and as to the
downstream use of the of the work i mean
there's a kind of judicial combe
artistic elitism going on here that Andy
Warhol was selling his artwork in with
those they hang in museums and Gary
sattar up whatever you think of his
artwork was selling it on t-shirts and
you know fairly cheap reproductions and
the like and so one is art and one isn't
and I tried to
suggest throughout the talk that context
may really be quite important do you see
a work at an art gallery or do you see
a-- do you just buy it off the back of a
turnip truck or on ebay and put it onto
your into your DVD and so these are
factors that judges are having to face
all the time you know we may all those
of us who are artists may feel a little
bit smug will say well you know we're
never going to be merely making
likenesses for raw commercial purposes
and selling them on key chains like Gary
sattar up but what does that say about
sort of the appropriation artists use in
fact is in the business of making money
and selling images that she makes so I'm
still not sure how I come out on that
but I do note that there is a kind of
elitist aesthetic that's permeating
through the judicial doctrine in this
area yes yeah it's a brilliant question
and it's something that I know it's
something I deal with every day and I'm
joined in the front row here by easton
ikos the director of publications at the
college art association who grapples
with this issue every day so let's start
with the easy part of it old means
anything that's in the public domain so
there's a very complex calculation to
determine what is in the public domain
in general works created before 1923 in
the United States would be in the public
domain but their works created after
that date that would be in the public
domain second yes it has very profound
implications for people who are certain
copyright / digital images or slides of
public domain work up until this
decision the bridgeman decision museums
and many others art slides purveyors
were asserting copyright in the
photograph of the pub
domain work so their photo of the Mona
Lisa was in copyright as I said at the
very beginning photographs historically
are subject to copyright this decision
suggests that if you're basically making
a slavish technically perfect
reproduction of the underlying public
domain work you cannot assert copyright
now you could assert some kind of
contractual right I on the slide I give
you the slide only if you sign a
contract that says I'll never use it
except for showing it in the classroom
you could if the individual then takes
that's the image on the slide and uses
it in an art book or put some on a
website you have a breach of contract
action but you don't have a copyright
infringement action now I need to say
about that case that that case was
decided here in New York by a single
district judge so in point of fact in
pure legal sense only is binding or has
application actually in Manhattan but no
other court has come out any other way
and it is a kind of precedent that at
least people in their artistic
publishing practices are following yes
sir yeah so obviously there's no
difference between a mountain in an old
master painting from what I've just said
they're both in the public domain but
the difference that the court was
drawing was between mere technical skill
and making up sort of faithful
reproduction of a work and the kind of
artistic inspiration that we would see
in Ansel Adams or any other very very
famous photographer whether it's avedon
or cartier assault and I think the view
is that all of those people were doing
quite a lot in terms of lighting
composition the moment and that the
skill being deployed and displayed by
these world famous photographers is
quintessential creative artistic
expression as is by the way you standing
at the foot of Manhattan and taking a
picture of the statute of liberty unless
you're a world-famous photographer
yourself you would be in a different
category except that what you're doing
is displaying some sort of artistic
innovation and creativity even though
that picture maybe have been taken four
billion times your work is protected by
copyright and so there's a little bit of
a danger from the copyright owners
perspective in the implications of this
decision where does creativity stop and
technical skill pick up or the other way
around sherrie levine when she's
photographing the image of the Walker
Evans photo is in fact engaged in a very
slavish reproduction of the other lying
work it may suggest that there is
nothing more than mere technical skill
involved in what she's doing therefore
there her work is pure is purely at the
public domain there is no copyright
leaving aside that she was infringing
copyright but if she had been let's say
taking that kind of an photograph of a
19th century print somebody very well
could say that even though it's by
sherrie levine and is famous therefore
it is not protected
I copyright
it's an excellent question the questions
essentially the relationship between
international practice and domestic
practice particularly for museums and
whether the United States is leading the
way there are a few things to be said
first intellectual property laws are
territorial so each country as you said
has its own law cases are only
applicable within the boundaries of the
country there are no international
bodies that are trying to standardize
legal principles in this area except
that there are regional groupings like
the European community that have come
out with something called the copyright
directive that's trying to harmonize the
copyright laws among members of the
European Union there are groups that are
focusing on this and I've given talks to
museum organizations where people are
engaged in the study of contemporary art
practice in particular how works get
displayed in museums can you take a new
media work and show it in a museum in a
way that's different from the artists
original mystic intent the artist gives
it to the museum it's on VHS can you
copy it put it on DVD and show it on
through a DV on a DVD player that sort
of thing but with respect to the United
States taking the lead I think it is
fair to say first that there many more
cases that arise in this area in the
United States that's true in virtually
every area of the law it's certainly
true an intellectual property law it's
absolutely true in the case of the
intersection of new digital technologies
and intellectual property law second we
have far and away the most robust fair
you stalked we're the only country that
has a quote fair use doctrine so other
countries generally speaking are much
more protective of the artist than that
is to say the original artist the
copyright owner then we are we take
these for fair use factors and take them
seriously obviously Koons lost a case
and universal lost the case involving 12
monkeys but in general we take the fair
use doctrine quite seriously even though
it is vague and uncertain in its
application other countries don't have
is kind of a robust set of exceptions to
the rights of the copyright owner so
this is basically a better place in that
sense to be if you're an appropriation
artist what's extremely important though
and it's a subject for a whole other
talk if I'm ever invited back I may give
it on what about art that is kind of
made internationally and inherently
distributed internationally so if you're
a net based artist and your work is
created through a consortium of artists
working in a number of different
cultures and your work as accessible
everywhere in the world because it's
posted on a website you then in fact you
have to start paying attention to the
laws of countries outside the United
States because you may be infringing
rights in that country even though what
you may be doing in the United States is
protected under the fair use doctrine
but that as I say is a subject for
another another day all right thank you
very much